هذه المناظر الطبيعية
المليئة بالمداخن الخيالية
والكنوز الجوفية
ألهمت عمر لإنشاء فندق المتحف
نفسه عملاً فنياً أمضى
أكثر من عقدين من الزمان في
ترميم هذه
الأطلال والكهوف والمنازل التي
تعود إلى ألف عام إلى حالتها الأصلية مع بعض
الكماليات المضافة على  الطريق
هو منظر رائع هنا ، هذه
بحيرة حديقة إيدين التي تراها لدينا
الكثير من
الطيور الجميلة حولنا وتعال وقل
مرحبًا بك
[موسيقى]
أعتقد أننا حصلنا على أكثر قليلاً مما
كنا نتفاوض
عليه جيدًا ، كل هذا يحدث  هنا سأخبرك جيدًا ،
دعنا نذهب وهذا هو
جناح السلطان ،
جناح السلطان ، نعم ، لقد أقام الكثير من الملوك
والملكات هنا في الواقع ، لقد جاؤوا وأقاموا هنا
جناحًا فندقيًا في كهف مزين
بأعمال فنية أصلية
هذه غرفة النوم أوه
رائع جدًا ، متحف حي ، الجاكوزي
الذي يطل على أفضل منظر لكابادوكيا ،
مدخنة خرافية خاصة بك خارج النافذة ،
لقد بدأت للتو ولكني أستطيع بالفعل أن
أرى كيف تغيرت المناظر الطبيعية
إد أهل كابادوكيا وعلى
مر القرون
قاموا بتشكيلها مرة أخرى ،
وأتطلع
بفارغ الصبر إلى ليلتي في كهف كابادوكيا على
الرغم من كونه فاخرًا ريتشارد ،
استمتع بغرفتك ، استمتع بيوم جميل ،
شكرًا لك وداعًا